♪ (opening music) ♪
Flutter has a powerful animations engine
for adding motion
and effects to your Flutter app.
But sometimes, you just need
to do something simple--
like fading in a widget.
And Flutter has you covered.
Flutter has a bunch of transitions
ready to drop into your Flutter app.
Let's take a look at FadeTransition.
FadeTransition lets you fade
a widget in and out.
It takes a child and an animation.
But where does the animation come from?
Well, first, we create
an AnimationController
to set the duration,
and then we create an animation--
giving the start and end opacity values
and animating via the controller.
Finally, we start the animation
by calling forward on the controller.
It's a good idea to wrap
a FadeTransition in the StatefulWidget,
so you can manage its state
and clean up once it's done.
For more info on Fade
and other transitions,
head on over to flutter.io
♪ (music) ♪